hello everyone and welcome back to the
clutch international tournament
uh it's magnus cross and versus jeffrey
shiong we already checked out one game
uh but
this one it's uh it's just a super
thriller
it's a game three magnus one game one
and game two uh but this one it's uh
really really awesome i chose it uh
because of one
particular move that i really enjoyed
and i think you're gonna
enjoy it as well but uh we'll see when
we get to it
so uh without further ado uh let's check
it out can uh jung bounce back in the
match or will magnus continue his
onslaught
uh so knights to f3 magnus opens with
diretti
uh with knight f3 c5 and now e4 the best
kind of retti uh transposing into the
sicilian defense uh we have
d6 and now bishop to b5 chair going for
the rosso limo
uh we have bishop d7 blocking captures
and the knight captures on b7 and here
magnus just castles so this is nothing
uh fancy this has all been played before
knight f6
developing while attacking a pawn here
rookie one defending and now
rook to c8 we have c3
magnus prepares to strike in the center
and now e6 preparing to develop the dark
square bishop and of course castle to
safety
so d4 we have c captures on d4c captures
and
d5 now asking do you want to trade here
or
advance your opponent in the center if
you don't advance the pawn you don't
really
get to claim any sort of advantage uh
with white so you do have to go for e5
knights the e for n knight b to d2 uh
preparing the capture and then win a
pawn after captures and captures so
black always captures on d2 here we have
captures on d2
and now this is uh the reason why i
chose this game uh bishop capture san
diego is the move that
has always been played here but and it
does make sense where would you capture
with the queen
and the block the development of your
own uh dark square bishop but this is
exactly what magnus does
uh and it is one it is one of the
reasons why i chose this game and it is
already as a move 12 that we have a
completely new game
now what's the idea uh behind queen d2
obviously you've blocked your own dark
square bishop without uh
developing it you cannot develop your
rook the point is you want to go queen
f4 to g4
and then uh create all sorts of uh uh
nasty threats towards the black king as
uh the the center is static so
black will not be able to get any pieces
to the king's side the knight is unable
to join the defense
rook very very unlikely the bishop also
not so much
so it will be tough for black to defend
however this is not a bad position for
black
it's just a new position and uh well ah
xium will have to
uh make decisions uh as he makes the
moves so bishop to e7 he prepares the
castle and the queen to
f4 now as planned uh we have castles and
now queen the g4 making room for the
bishop to be developed
uh to h6 uh so rook to e8 making room
for bishop to f8 it will be
a valuable defender of the g7 pawn and
now just h4 magnus wants to play
h5 uh and so on so queen to c7 you don't
really have any
uh any other moves that are like active
or
or important here you just have to play
a very passive position and these
are the kinds of uh positions that i
really hate playing for for example with
black if white gets a d4
e5 and i have to defend with no pieces
to actually help defend my king
and now bishop to f8 of course is always
possible you can play the
this uh preemptively kinked h8 getting
out of this uh
getting out of the g file also a
possibility shion goes for queen to c7
uh he wants to bring the
queen over to c2 and then help out with
the defense with
the queen so bishop to h6 magnus forces
him to react now you either play g6 or
bishop to f8 bishop to f8 that does seem
to be
a more natural move for you to play
since uh you've prevented checkmate and
you haven't created any additional
weaknesses but qiung
goes for g6 now i'm sure there's a
reason for this but
it doesn't look natural to me i mean
bishop to f8 is a very natural square
for the bishop if you want to guard the
g7 pawn and also now you've just
created a weakness for white to attack
but okay queen to f
for now going after the f7 pawn now the
plan is the knight will come to g5 and
you will put pressure on f7
we have queen to c2 now again with the
idea of queen f5
just offering a queen trade but now
magnus goes g4 he doesn't allow it
and now black has to black has to figure
out a different way on how to approach
this now
while you could grab a pawn here uh it
doesn't really do all that much since a
white can just win it back whenever
white uh wants and you don't really want
to allow this so
b6 now black is preparing to capture on
b2 but now
magnus also just uh goes b3
uh so just b3 uh and now comes uh
and also yeah i forgot to mention like
here uh in this position like if you
want to offer a trader with bishop to f8
uh with the idea that you want to get
some pieces away from the attack it
actually
fails miserably to knight to g5 now the
f7 pawn is under attack you no longer
have rook to f8 so you have to defend
with rook to a7
but now your rook here is undefended so
now rook 8 to c1 just wins the game you
have to move the queen and you lose the
rook so
not possible so that's why b6 prepares
the capture on b2 with b3
and now bishop to a3
uh preparing to to get both rooks into
the game also now you will be
you will have the e7 square uh for your
rook to help out with the defense of the
pawn
uh but also uh what black wants to do is
play queen here put the rook here and
put some pressure on the f2 pawn
so king g2 magnus improves the position
of the king
before starting an attack and now queen
b2
with the idea of getting the the rook
over to c2
but now knight to g5 now the f7 point is
under attack you cannot go to f8 so rook
to e7
and now rook 8 to d1 just uh continuing
development uh adding another defender
to the pawn here
and you don't really care about the a2
pawn as you're all about
the attack this game so we have rook to
c2
of course putting pressure on f2 for the
moment you don't really
have a threat since the queen is uh
defending the pawn but
it is a much more active square for the
rook so rook to e3 by magnus he wants to
play the rook to f3 to add another
attacker to the f7 pawn and also another
defender to the f2 pawn and xiong
doesn't allow this
rook to c3 but now h5 it was
bound to happen at some point uh and
here queen to c2 once again uh preparing
uh
queen to f5 after maybe this trade
happened so the the g
point the g pawn moves uh but uh now
black's position is completely lost
so feel free to pause the video here and
try to find the winning move for magnus
while i give you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on spotting
this idea as it's not easy to find and
for those of you who just want to enjoy
the show it's either rook captures on c3
or knight captures on h7
uh both moves are basically the same
idea so you either capture on c3 first
and then on h7 or on h7 first and then
on c3
magnus captured on c3 first the queen is
under attack so you have to capture
and now comes knight captures on h7 and
it comes
with a most wonderful idea uh that after
king
if you don't capture this you're just
dead lost there's nothing nothing to be
done here
so king captures and now the star move
bishop to g5 now attacking the rook and
if you move the rook then queen captures
on f7 is completely winning
so king the g8 you have to add a
defender here
but now just bishop captures on e7 we
have bishop captures on e7
and now rook to c1 after the queen moves
the rook is coming to c8 so everything
is connecting perfectly
uh queen back to b4 and now rook the c8
with
check uh if you move the king it's not
all that impressive if you go here then
the f7 pawn falls so you have to go here
uh but then h6 check uh and again it's
not
not not fun queen captures here king
captures here
and now king to g3 uh preparing to to
deliver the
the final blow and if you block this
let's say we knight to f8 and rook to c1
coming to rook to h1
and it's a game over so after rook to c8
we have
knight to f8 blocking uh but now h6
and now the threat is if you try
something like queen to b5
then uh the point is you have to go into
this end game which will be winning for
white h7 check
uh the king has to go away either
capture and then queen captures on f7
happens or king g7 and then you bring a
queen into the game with
check captures and only then queen
captures on f7
and now the point is after any move that
black makes so let's say queen to e2
you can either capture here or you can
go for something like queen captures on
g6 win some pawns first and then uh
uh either uh follow it up by by by a
similar idea or black can outrage queens
uh but even though black has a bishop
and knight for a rook you will uh you
will easily win uh
the queen side points you will easily
win this pawn and you're just they're
gonna be much better and easily winning
so after h6 uh xion played g5
as the bishop is guarding this so uh
hopefully now you can win this
but it still doesn't work so for the
last time uh feel free to pause the
video and
find the winning blow for white well
i'll give you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on spotting uh
the same idea again yes it is h7 for
those of you who just want to enjoy the
show
and that's just it so now you don't have
you don't have a move if you're captured
in queen captures on f7 is winning
so king to g7 but again uh h8 with queen
with king captures an h8 and now queen
captures an f7
uh xiung captured on d4 but now magnus
goes for
rook captures on f8 he goes into this
queen's end game
uh but as you'll see it is uh not not
very
uh well it's it's no longer a thriller
of a game
so bishop captures we have queen
captures and f8 with check king h7
and now a few checks to pick up some
pawns uh with tempo
so queen f7 check king has to move now
comes queen to h5 check the king has to
go to the g
file king g7 now the g5 pawn falls with
check so queen captures on g5 with
check h7 and now queen to e7 with
check king h8 and now queen to f6 check
king to h7 and finally queen captures an
e6 where both of the past pawns
are nicely defended so black doesn't
really have a lot of counter play here
if you try some checks queenie for
checking g3 queen d3 check after f3
there are no more checks so now you are
free to start
checking and pushing your past pawn so
xiong tried queen to d1
uh but magnus just goes queen to f5
check he makes room for his pass pawn
king g8 and e6
and it was in this position that jeffrey
xiong resigned the game
and magnus takes a a three to zero lead
in the match
uh here again you don't really have any
checks queen f7 check followed by
e7 e8 is coming and that's just it
uh so that's the game i do hope you
enjoyed it i really i really enjoyed it
because of
well especially because of this position
and not bishop captures but rather queen
captures probably something magnus
uh had at home in his home laboratory at
some point thought oh okay this might be
an interesting idea if black's not
careful i might be able to develop a
fierce attack which is exactly what
happened here
and if you play the rosso limo you know
black might uh
defend in a similar way you will know
some uh ideas for for how to use the
attack
so once again i do hope you enjoyed it i
would like to thank jonas hilston
uh burke listener uh charlie hill
garrett graham and bradley
varley for a contribution to my channel
thank you a lot i really appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and
i will see you soon continuing the
coverage of the clutch international
will be checking up on pogchamps
continuing the morphe saga
checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and so on so thank you all i
will see you soon and have an excellent
rest of your day